welcome back to new rockstars one
division's opening two episodes have us
asking
who is that beekeeper and uh that's not
even the weirdest question
we have about this show we're gonna get
that honey
as well as the deeper question of how
vision is back and why i only enjoy him
in ghost form i'm eric boss this is
rogue theory with me today is an amazing
pocket reality of nerds including inside
marvel co-host jessica clements
hello i'm very excited to talk more
about wanda vision i know none of you
are upset or
tired of me doing it oh we're very
excited
also with us confirmed honey trap tommy
beck told you catch more bees with honey
baby
and i gotta say i've been watching uh
yours and jessica's
after show for just on repeat for days
and i still don't know what i saw
but great job by you guys i'm very funny
tommy you don't catch bees with honey
bees make honey you catch flies with
honey
bees don't go back to their own products
you catch more flies with honey and you
kill more bees with money
by paying b assassins yeah stop paying
those assassins we need bees
uh hey we're also thrilled to have back
to the show writer and comedian john
xavier miller
welcome back john hello hello i don't
have any marvel
shirts so i apparently decided that a
star wars shirt was
appropriate the crossover is bound to
happen okay so
by now we have seen one division episode
two and we've met that beekeeper
uh after an episode filled with bumps in
the night at least one of them that toy
helicopter with a sword logo
wanda envisioned at the end of the
episode see this beekeeper climbing out
of a manhole
in west view and then you can see a
sword logo on the back of his suit
and then he whip turns to look at wanda
and wanda's like ah
nope and then she rewinds the episode
kind of like a vhs tape
essentially pretending this beekeeper
doesn't exist now if you're wondering
who this
is the actor in that beekeeper suit is
named zach henry he's a stunt actor for
the show
on a bunch of marvel productions
actually it's not aaron taylor johnson
it's not eddie redmayne
it's not the jeans guy from the
mandalorian but we have seen other promo
footage of
this sword agent whoever he is entering
the pocket reality and coming through as
a person in a beekeeper suit and i think
we can assume based on that that he is
on the same probing mission that monica
rambo
is he's part of sword but the question
is why the beekeepers suit
what does the bee keeper suit represent
to wanda
did that sword agent dress as a
beekeeper before entering the bubble or
did the bubble
warp him into a beekeeper i'm going to
open it up to you guys and let's start
by looking at this possibility of this
goofy theory that all the hexagon
imagery
could imply that we are looking at a
kind of hive that
westview might be a honeycomb structure
a hive
with wanda as the queen bee everyone
else is a drone
do we think there's any truth to this
you know what i'm gonna jump in this i'm
gonna jump in this head first and say
i feel like i get where you're coming
from saying that wanda
might be the queen bee i completely get
it uh we could also
be introduced to swarm and why wouldn't
we be introduced to swarm this way
because
that would give reason for all the
hexagons and all that sweet sweet
craziness that we're getting
also what's more horrific what's more
horrific than a man whose body is just
made entirely of bees
yes explain to us whose swarm is in the
spiderman comics
yes yes yes yes so if you guys haven't
seen swarm swarm has been a little bit
in television actually on a lot of
amazing spider-man and all of the
animation that's been going on recently
but he's also really big in the comic
book so what he was really brought into
the world was in champions
where essentially swarm is a nazi not
essentially he's a nazi he's a nazi
scientist
um and when he and after world war ii he
went to
uh he went to i think colombia he went
to colombia
don't quote me on that but he left he
ran away after world war ii
and became like basically a beekeeper
and found this hive that was different
than all the others and it was a bunch
of bees that were mutated he thought
oh i'm gonna use these bees to take over
the world made a device to turn these
bees into evilness but
actually just made them pissed off where
they ate his entire flesh
and became him and all he has left is a
skeleton underneath this pile of bees
and anytime the bees leave if the queen
bee is like distraught
and leaves the bees leave with her and
then we're left with a skeleton man that
just falls to the ground
horrifying the idea of seeing this
and he is the like villain to spider-man
the villain arguably not but he is one
of many villains to spider-man
okay hey i i love the concept of swarm
this is not swarm it's a guy in a
beekeeper suit it's not a man made of
bees
i disagree i disagree thank you he
doesn't want that
disney doesn't want that visual haunting
children so he's just gonna be
in a hat suit with some bees floating
around first of all
b b's on a skeleton is my favorite snack
next to ants on a log uh it's delicious
i make bees on a skeleton from my niece
and nephews every summer
on a hot day and you had me at nazi made
of bees
uh jessica i i had never heard of swarm
before
but now that i know that swarm exists uh
as a sort of sentient swarm of bees
i feel like it has to be it's either him
or randall park right it's randall park
or swarm that's the two those are my two
front runners
yes thank you thank you why would it be
randall park if it's
if it's the face of this other white
dude why would randall park
be warp into a white dude i didn't see
that i didn't see that it was a white
man's face
see you watch you watch these more in
depth than i do i thought the face was
obscured
we'll just cut that out then it wasn't
randall park
no we're going to lead the episode with
that it has to be randall park
it must be him well john which do you
think sounds crazier
the idea that we would have a b nazi or
a nazi b
man or that this could all be some kind
of weird extended metaphor
of all of that town being a beehive i
think
the bee hive metaphor makes more sense
to me at least because i feel like wanda
is obviously
in control of everything and like
whether or not she's like
explicitly like telling everyone what to
do i feel like
her control over everything is telling
everybody you know what to do
yeah she's the queen bee and i think
when she's not
paying attention that's when things kind
of
drift a little bit or shift and i love
the idea i
i think the guy in the beekeeper suit i
think he's wearing like a hazmat suit
and once he's like in her reality if
wanda is like this is the 1960s
the closest thing she can approximate to
that
is like a beekeeper's suit because it
has that kind of helmet on it's
you know full suit i think she's kind of
just changing him a little bit
and when she sees it she's like this
isn't in my script uh
rewind let's rewrite it this is it in my
world
interesting and that's uh that brings up
a very interesting idea john because
uh we know from trailer footage that
monica rambo
is gonna get ejected from this reality
and when she lands outside the reality
she's still wearing her 70s clothes
so this beekeeper presumably when he
gets ejected or if he leaves
he's going to be in the beekeeper suit
that he was warped into
suggesting that wanda's reality warping
extends outside the town is this gonna
be like a like
truman show type thing where all of the
sword agents are gonna be
costumed actors and professional like
entertainers that have come in
to kind of play in wanda's world like
that would be an interesting thing if
they show
them all getting assigned different
period appropriate costuming and
and maybe even dialogue or like
vocabulary that could be kind of cool
yeah and then the b man comes out of
nowhere and his skeleton collapses i'm
just saying i still think it's time
i'm gonna hold on yeah it's i'm gonna
hold on to this forever because it was
also in the truman show i remember that
scene
it brings up an interesting question as
well right like how many people
in this town are in on it uh to me it
seems like you have certain residents
you have people like uh
herb you have jones you have dottie uh
who are just residents of west view then
you have people like agnes who is
playing her own game i feel
and then you have people like geraldine
slash monica and then this beekeeper
who are uh we presume sword agents so
i don't know if all the people in
westview are sword agents and some of
them are just better actors at tricking
wanda into thinking they belong
than others i think so i think you have
three different categories right you
have
the west view residents who are probably
imprisoned or trapped there
uh you have agnes uh and then you have
uh you have the sword infiltrators eric
eric it could be like a b colony you
have
you have the drones which are the bees
that are just
doing their singular task and are
unaware of
what they're supposed to be doing then
you have the honeycomb bees they have
the honeybees
that are actually manufacturing
something the actors the sword agents
the the outside forces that have come in
and then you have the queen bee
the queen of all of the hive which is
wanda
and then you have then you have the half
robot half human vision i don't know
what he is
in b terms maybe he's a hornet he's a
murder hornet okay i was on tommy's side
up until then
but i think tommy is very very on to
something i think that is very true
because also when we get the second
episode of like for the children
the bees are helping the mom the queen
bee
procreate make more babies because all
the babies all the like drones all the
male bees and the bee hive i follow a
lot of b
tick talkers tick-tockers all the male
bees basically
like even side note in the winter if
there's male bees that don't work they
get kicked out of the hype but
they basically are just there to serve
the queen bee that's all they're good
there to do
they always feed her and then she has
cer like subservants that like bathe her
clean her
feet her but the rest of them are
basically getting all the pollen and
doing all that stuff
so what if the ones closest to her are
those bees that are the subordinates but
then we have the bigger ones that are
like
we're here to take care of you as well
so tommy
yeah tommy unless you
somehow cheated and like found answers
in disney's like
bunker i i think tommy's right i think
i think we're right together with our
co-author no longer do i believe in
swarm now
i swatted that theory
the um the one thing that i think goes
against the hive theory
is that a queen bee is not monogamous
and
it seems like there's a core
relationship in this show wanda and
vision their names are sandwiched
together in the title
uh i don't think one has got any side
action she
is in a loving monogamous relationship
with vision and that's not how bees work
well
boring boring
i forgot they made this show just to
entertain tommy i need wanda to be very
horny and very promiscuous
oh king tommy we could do better jester
uh entertainment for you messiah
i find you boring i'm bored
throw him in the snake that's for me
jester send him to the bees
it would be a great show if tommy was
the master of it there are other reasons
there could be a beekeeper that are just
simpler
right like um this idea i mean what
what are bees for in ecology they are
there
to pollinate they're there to kind of
keep the fabric of an ecosystem
together um we learned this from jerry
seinfeld's
uh masterpiece the b movie one of my
favorite movies you'd be a fool not to
see it
shut up tommy so go with me on this guys
um the idea that we've heard we've seen
a couple
shout outs to flowers you know when
vision looked outside the window he's
like oh it's just your rose bushes
when they walk by dottie's house they're
like oh those flowers will grow under
the penalty of death
um there's this rose this digital rose
in the closing credits
maybe sword's mission is to bring in
these outside bees
and to kind of cross pollinate and to
turn flower by flower into technicolor
to try to wake wanda out of this spell
out of this trance
to say like we're bringing an outside
pollen and that outside
influence brings uh kind of an outside
life and breaks the bubble
am i reaching that's insane i don't
think it's reaching though
well that's crazy that's a crazy idea so
you're saying that like
bit bit by bit they'll be establishing
reality in this unrealistic world the
bee's job is to bring
wanda out to reality yeah uh and i think
that's that's what sword's mission is
and it seems contrary
to what uh agnes and some of the members
of west view would want
there's that moment where agnes like
she's like do not be yourself
and she got so threatened when wanda was
just gonna be herself
and then she like laughs it away like it
seems like there's some it's not
the community versus wanda there's like
the community versus wanda and then
other uh infiltrators other third
parties in that community
so it's kind of a war on all fronts i
wanted to ask you guys do you think it's
possible that the
that it could be more personal for wanda
just the image of a beekeeper is
something from wanda's past
you know we've had these commercials
where it's the stark toaster where it's
the hydro watch
and these are all things from sokovia
like that that beeping we kind of
theories that the toaster could be
this the stark bomb that never went off
that that traumatized
um wanda and pietro so maybe the
beekeeper could be another thing like
the
the someone from her past maybe her
father magneto was into beekeeping
or just someone uh or she saw someone in
a hazmat suit in the fallout of sokovia
in that past conflict and now it
connects with her in that beekeeper
that's why she changes them
from a hazmat to a beekeeper to try to
like avoid that
retriggering dug back up trauma
i think john was pretty spot on with
saying that it was
someone coming from the outside world
coming in because also to add
on to that there's probably a like this
is a stretch
possibly but like if wanda is in charge
of this reality and what we're seeing
right now
it was the middle of the night she was
too busy and she wasn't too busy she was
kissing her husband and they found out
that she was pregnant and maybe she
skipped
and didn't notice that someone has
already broken into the reality or into
her reality
so that's why the hazmat man was moving
so slowly and shiftly and that is like
in that time like a hazmat was the
closest thing to it a beekeeper
and the bees and that's like what her
real her thought consciousness did
so i maybe i think john is also right
i'm i keep writing other people's
coattails
i think john is correct but let me tell
you why
but no i i do think he's i think that's
like spa yeah i also agree that john
is correct yes i saw i have a question
for you
when uh wanda or when the beekeeper whip
turns his head over at wanda do you
think that was a threatening gesture or
do you think he was
afraid like he was like they
spotted me i did not think they'd be out
right now like was he afraid or was he
uh
a threat i think he's afraid because i
mean i've watched the marvel movies i
don't think any just regular guy could
just like
show up near wanda and just be like hey
i'm here to fight you
like she's extremely powerful and i
think
that he was like i'm gonna sneak through
like these like pretend
sewers and you know like and he's like
oh she's out in the front yard
i think he's absolutely afraid because
if somebody was powerful enough to fight
her
he wouldn't need that hazmat suit and
that's on period
hey and uh let's remember this guys uh
this guy's wearing what we think could
have been a hazmat suit or some kind of
protective gear
monica rambo is also in this reality
pretending to be geraldine
why doesn't she need protective gear why
is she just wearing
period appropriate wardrobe does she
already have powers
i was gonna say i don't think she's
pretending i think that she's
i think she's under one dispel i think
maybe
there was some kind of interaction prior
to this and she was like
with wanda or near wanda when she
decided to make her own reality
and now monica is just that's why i
think maybe she's strong enough that she
was like
wait what's my oh geraldine i think that
she
i think that she's just trapped i think
she's like one of these like
not an actor but she's like a real
person who wanda has
written this backstory for and put these
memories in her head
i don't think she remembers who she is
very very good point
and i think what we're kind of arriving
at the conclusion here
is that all these people are a little
afraid of wanda in particular
um whether she's a queen bee or just the
star of the show to use agnes words
she might be the villain of this series
and all these other people are just
trying to control her or use her or
write her coattails
but by the end of it we might see the
origin story of marvel's next big
villain
here right now which is very exciting
well because this is still rogue theory
and because i just do this all the time
i am mentally awarding points to you as
you are talking
sorry that's just how my world works and
um
jessica gets the golden sparkle book
um for backing down from your swarm
theory
little humility goes a long way okay
okay
you know what i'll let that slide i'll
let that slide because i get a golden a
golden
book uh there's still more chances to
earn bucks guys i'm not going to tell
you what the rules are it's just
you know we'll see i got to earn those
bucks so
there's a lot more to talk about with
wanda vision we're going to talk about
vision and how that synthesized
is standing once more but first you may
have noticed i
am wearing our new latest obsession
shirt
new rockstars and our merch partners at
epic hero shop have two
really cool new wanda vision inspired
t-shirt designs and
newrockstarsmerge.com
each shirt has an augmented reality
element built into it this
is the um the male uh the android the
synthezoid of the two
uh it's really really cool it's so cozy
you can get this at newaxersmerch.com
and if you get it this one in particular
you will have the option to get an
on-screen
shout out in our inside marvel after
show so yeah be sure to get your hands
on that there's also the wanda version
at epic hero shop.com as well
um ooh also epic here shop is giving
away 10 ps5s folks
all you got to do is subscribe to their
youtube channel epic hero labs
and fill out the form that you'll find
at epic heroshop.com giveaway every 10
000 subscribers there will be a new
winner announced
there's a bunch of ways to get more
entries into the giveaway at that
website so check it out epic hero
shop.com
giveaway and uh let's thank some friends
who helped us make this episode starting
with our friends at
manly bands so lots of guys don't put
much thought into their wedding ring
and jewelry stores know this manly bands
is here to rescue you from an otherwise
hellish
banned buying experience man in the
bands offers your hand the freedom to
look how you want it to look
in just about every type of earthly
material imaginable so my
precious is made of cobalt chrome and it
is called
the novelist to channel my inner hamming
way
not the way his life ended just you know
what his life was so here's what you do
you use the manly
ring sizer from manly bands to find your
perfect fit and then you pick from their
insane selection of materials they got
gold wood antler
steel dinosaur bone and even meteorite
what they got all this stuff and you can
also choose from one of the manly band's
curated collections like the
jack daniels whiskey barrel collection
even if you've been married for a while
getting yourself a new band is a fun way
to mix things up without needing to mix
up your spouse
now once you've selected your band manly
bands offers free shipping worldwide a
30-day exchange policy
and a free warranty while there might be
a 50
chance your marriage won't work out
there's a 100 chance that you're gonna
love
your band to order your manly band and
get twenty percent off plus a free
silicone ring go to manlybands.com
rogue and enter the promo code rogue
that's manlybands.com
rogue into the code rogue for 20
off manly bands the best damn rings
period
we also want to thank our friends at
expressvpn for sponsoring this episode
you probably don't want a random
passerby looking in on you while you use
the bathroom right
i hope you don't want that you might
want it but this ad
isn't for you um so why would you let
people look in on you when you go
online well using the internet without
expressvpn is like going to the bathroom
and not closing the door your internet
service provider knows every single
website you visit
oh and what's worse is they can sell
this information to ad companies and
tech giants who will use your data to
target you
expressvpn puts a stop to this it
creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so that your online
activity can't be seen by anyone it's
like a tunnel of love
just for you by yourself doing one of
these
i realize loving yourself by yourself is
why a lot of people
go online and why a lot of people don't
want people knowing where they're going
well i use expressvpn on all my devices
it works on everything
phones laptops even routers so that
everyone who shares your wi-fi
can still be protected even if they
don't have expressvpn isn't that great
and the best part is using an express
cpn is as easy as closing the bathroom
door you just fire up the app you click
one button and you're protected
expressvpn is the world's number one
rated vpn by cnet wired
and the verge and countless others so if
you are like me and believe your online
activity is your business alone
secure yourself by visiting
expresscpn.com rogue today
use my exclusive link
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
rogue and you can get an extra three
months for free that's expressvpn.com
rogue all right let's get back to one
division y'all while uh
this show is back there's still too many
questions to feel totally safe and
secure
one of those is how is vision alive
again
what form of vision are we really
looking at what does his return
in the show mean for the nature of this
reality
uh let's assume vision's death and
infinity war was permanent
so if that is the case how is he back
now
and i'll lead off this conversation by
saying it looks like
vision might be the show's point of view
character more than wanda
is he does seem to be the most
reactionary to what's going on
so what are we looking at is he simply
wanda's imaginary friend is this all in
her head as has been suggested
oh i was gonna say i think that he's
real because
there are scenes that happen when she's
not there
so like it'd be one thing if they're
always together
but if he's not real then why did she
need to like you know
make him go to the library and learn
about the neighborhood watch like or go
to work
you know that's why i think that he's
not alive
is because i think that like i think she
if she did create this entire bubble
this is this little
town is all of her imagination i think
so is
vision and they're like tangentially
like connected and that's why they both
don't know
the answers to the same things so like
when people harass vision with
and wanda with questions they're both
confused and it's like
not to judge robots but vision is a
computer a super computer he's very
smart
he'd probably know things that wanda
might not know but they both equally
don't know the same thing so i think
that she's creating him with the best
memory she can but why
if that is what happened why why did the
gum affect him
so physiologically why why that's true
why did the gun bother him
here's what i really hope is not the
case
i know that that's counterintuitive to
rogue theory here's my bogue
bogus theory this better not be taking
place
in the time period between civil war and
infinity war
when they were hiding together yeah this
better not be
a old timeline event that took place
like
like a year before the events of
infinity war or i'm going to
go on top of a tall building and curse
kevin feige
to the gods and and then that'll be and
then go to
dairy queen and get a cheese quake and
settle down that'll be what i'll do
it might it completely all she did was
watch tv
that's all she did i don't think so i
think i think they think this has been
confirmed to
be taking place after end game i don't
think that's anywhere established in the
episodes we've seen i just think
somewhere in an interview feige or jack
shafer has said this is after end game
but i agree with you if they suddenly
say oh this is before infinity war i'm
gonna be
annoyed under my desk my hand just like
went like this as tommy was saying it
that's some game of thrones season seven
right there let's talk about this
theory that what we're seeing right now
is kind of uh visions ai digital
consciousness
after it was partially downloaded by
shuri in infinity war
and somehow this was saved on a server
and that uh
you know in the way that ultron awakened
by combing through
history including tv history uh that's
kind of what we're seeing with vision
now it's like his process of rebooting
inside
his head so this is kind of like barf
yeah maybe we are seeing a version of
barf i mean we have seen promo footage
showing these big
football stadium light towers that seem
to be lighting
up this town or they kind of form the
perimeter fence
we could be seen barf my only uh
objection to barf would be
that in the most recent marvel property
we saw
a spider-man far from home it was all
revealed to be barf
and if it was just another thing it's
gonna be like is everything barf
in marvel's future now i'm stomped by
that maybe
it's maybe it's a little too complicated
i think for most people
the reason and for me included the
reason i would
maybe say there's something to this are
these closing credits in which it all
looks to be very digital
and technological as opposed to magic
you know um it it doesn't look like
we're going into the daily profit
uh where everything's kind of like
magical and moving around it looks like
we're looking at pixels realigning in a
tv screen
so are you saying that sword is putting
these images into her head or are you
saying that sword is just recreating all
of this
i i don't know how i got confused there
was just one part where i was like
wait a minute what do you mean what are
you talking about
is this i think the question is is this
technology
being used to suppress wanda's magic
and like in rare moments she's able to
use her magic again
but for the most part is this like is
this is this
ai being used to keep her from using her
magic and freeing herself
so when she does rewind that's almost
like muscle memory force use where it's
like oh
she can pull herself out to do that but
then she immediately goes
right like is there something so
powerful being uploaded into her that
she can't
uh she can't break free and use her
powers
yeah i mean that is a possibility what
i'm just saying is that
we have been looking at this in one
direction that sword has been playing
catch-up to whatever is happening to
wanda and they're just monitoring it and
trying to
contain it but it might be the other way
around like maybe what we're looking at
is a sword experiment with
wanda's consent gone awry that they
wanted to work with wanda to try to do
something whether it's to
reincarnate vision um and it just didn't
work
because there's this third party a fly
in the ointment that fly
being uh agnes or you know some dark
entity mephisto
or nightmare or the grim reaper and when
um when jimmy was saying wanda's what's
do who's doing this to you
he is saying like he's saying hey wanda
you and i have this like communication
network that we're trying to reach each
other that's all normal because we've
had this experiment set up
is there someone else in there with you
who's screwing this all up
that could be what we're seeing i always
i keep forgetting about that
who's doing this to you and it never
that like never sits right with what i
think
the show is about because like i might
think i'm like oh
she's in control she's creating this
reality but if that's true then why is
he asking who's doing this to you
so now i'm like well then right now then
i don't know what that is then
because yeah and the question of that
question is not
who it's this what is this doing
this to you like is this being like the
glitches
or all of this who's doing all of this
to you or who is ruining this experiment
you know i gotta do one of these
sentence graphing of every word in that
sentence has a question to it but let's
entertain this notion of
maybe this is referring to wanda and
agnes using dark magic to resurrect
vision and that's how vision is back
like uh
jessica and i were kind of talking about
maybe the experiment was
wanda finding this friend agnes who's
like hey i'm a witch too
i have this book called the dark hold it
there's a spell in this i can resurrect
your android friend because he did have
a soul
and we can bring him back and then that
spell goes awry
in a kind of technological form to
create west view as we see it in these
two episodes
do you guys think that's more likely
that we're going to see some more dark
magic
influences yes i want there to be
without a doubt
but like the entertainment knowledge
that i have in my head i just don't
think disney will get too far into it
i would love it yeah i love it and
with the inside marvel the fans have now
they're like oh jessica's really into
this dark magic stuff and i'm like yeah
i love it but like realistically
i think disney's gonna be too afraid of
it so they're gonna tiptoe the line of
it
that is my gun instinct too jessica but
then over halloween
you can watch hocus pocus on disney plus
which deals with them talking about
fornicating with
you know that's they love that kind of
magic dark magic stuff
there are witches in most of these
disney movies from snow white the first
one you know
in the early days they kind of love
sorcery
and demonic stuff but for fun fans that
love hocus pocus it didn't do that well
when it originally dropped it became a
cult classic over time
so i think because it was a cult classic
disney was like we're checking it we put
it on our platform
it's so big but that is true that is
true it's still on that platform they're
still
viewing it like you have to go to disney
to watch it unless you're buying it on
amazon i guess but it's like you still
so it's like they still
let it slide i just maybe the agnes one
i want it to be so dark
that it's like jessica they'll do dark
just not you're dark they're not gonna
straight up be like she's coming out of
hell here comes the devil
like like she's not gonna do crazy stuff
so maybe you you could be right you
could be completely right and then that
also
ties in with like the trailer that we
got where ag or well agnes was like
am i dead because you are like that
scene of like maybe she is one of the
people that wasn't controlled by mafesto
she like came out of it and was like
am i dead but then maybe she comes back
too and she's like hey
i'm joking one last theory i want to get
each of your thoughts on
uh is it possible that vision himself
could be mephisto that vision could be
the devil
taking the form of vision just to screw
with wanda and that all the little
uh reactions we've seen from vision are
an act
i would love that so much i would love
that so much i think
that's too dark for disney
[Laughter]
that is really yeah i think i think that
and i also think that like my same
reasoning for why i think vision is
alive and the same thing that like
if that is mafesto pretending to be
vision
then again we still wouldn't need those
scenes of him
at the neighborhood watch like you know
this idea
in my mind that it's really happening in
real time that
he wouldn't need to do you know if he's
off stage with wanda he doesn't need to
do anything
you know that's not for anybody's
benefit or his vision an avatar
is vision another is like his vision an
agent of sword that is
wearing a vision skin basically like a
video game
there's basically just the idea that the
familiarity between
vision and and wanda is because she has
a friendly relationship with whatever
sword agent
is posing as vision so like maybe the
emotions are somewhat genuine
but they're just not authentically
vision
and that would explain why that pov
exists in scenes away from wanda because
it is a
still a living entity it's just not the
one that we see
right in front of us and if mafesto is
in that world that could give two
reasons to a
memphis was like this is also messing
with her more the fact that like
vision is in that world and sword is
playing them
mafesto could be like this is not
helping anything so let's keep it in
here
or mafesto could just be waiting for a
moment to be like
psych god and rip him apart in front of
wanda to make her go like
even more chaotic i bring up the theory
i'm not so certain about it just because
from what we have seen so far
vision seems kind of the least likely
character to
have um some kind of devilish secret
he seemed even wanda seems to be more
potentially the villain of the series
and vision is vision is pure reaction
and he seems like a truly human version
of himself the fact that he was drunk
and so
unhinged uh in episode two on this gum
like i don't think uh mephista would let
himself
get to that point you know uh and
especially you're right john he was not
in the room with wanda when that
happened so it just seems like he's kind
of on his own
bumbling trajectory and he's just he's
been dragged into this
i don't think he's the one who's uh
behind everything orchestrating it
pulling the strings
so i think we got to some interesting
possibilities of how vision could be
back
personally i feel like it is either um
it's a sword experiment gonorrhea or
agnes and wanda did some kind of
witchcraft to
resurrect a piece of him uh and that
they made a deal with the devil
in order to make this happen uh and you
know where i'm at with mephisto i kind
of want it to be the latter
um but the golden sparkle book
goes to tommy
the idea of someone else wearing a
vision suit
a vision skin suit i love that i never
thought that life would be anything but
catastrophe but suddenly i begin to see
a little good luck for me
cause i've got a golden sparkle bark
it's yours tommy
i didn't like that last part
look
um we are moving on to rogue questions
we have uh some questions i want to hear
some answers from you guys
first off set photos from spider-man the
third spider-man movie show that the
movie is going to be set during
christmas
what do you think peter parker wants for
mj little mj under the tree and
uh some bro time with his buddy
[Laughter]
um i think he wants his his uncle back
uncle ben
oh yeah forget about uncle ben he wants
aunt may to stop seeing that guy
what's his name yeah i think he wants
you to stop
seeing each other he's going to be like
stop this i mean
he wants to destroy a relationship i
mean the real answer is probably a ps5
right like the real answer is
peter parker probably wants a ps5 yeah
he wants a ps5
which is
[Laughter]
uh tommy i'm gonna give you the point
for that one
yes uh you're right subscribe to epic
hero labs
tell us what that is please i'm banned
i'm banned from epic hero labs all right
we have one more question disney is
putting all episodes of the 1970s muppet
show on disney plus
next month who is the best muppet and
why
um okay oh okay
give me a second jessica is glitching
like deborah joe rupp in episode one
like
okay okay okay does
groups count do groups of muppets count
or should we just go with one more yes
yes muppet teams depending on that i
might allow it there's so many people
just give me some time i have
this is so embarrassing i have a
document on my computer of my favorite
muppets
um and i'm looking at it right now it
was for it was for a pr
i swear i swear to god it was for
something it wasn't just me being like a
crazy person but
i do so i'm looking at it and i'm like
no it's weird
no it's not weird first of all first of
all first of all first of all
we gotta get uh on the internet trending
jessica
unleash the muppets document we must
have the muppets document
released the people must know
how you rank these muppets where is new
zealand
he can throw a fish like a boomerang i
don't even want to talk about this
document i'm very embarrassed of it
let's just name off our favorite one
no we want to know what's in this
document who are your muppet alignments
okay so i'm not going to say this one
because i'm thinking about the ticket so
i want to win the ticket
of course i put miss piggy as first i
mean look at me like of course i put
miss piggy as first
like she's an icon and i always looked
up to her as a child
and animalist
too yeah i love animals because animals
are
chaotic yes he's like everyone's like
he's chaotic chaotic but he's like
chaotic neutral like
when you think about it in the muppet
world he's very
in the mind he is chaotic nature
um i put beaker as my throat but keep
going sorry you guys choose yours you
choose yours and i'm gonna keep looking
at my dog
i'm getting that i want that doc out
john what do you think the only muppet i
can think of besides miss piggy and
kermit
is beaker and i'm going with beaker i
have no reason
behind it i don't think about the
muppets enough
but now i want to go to disney world to
go muppets 4d
that was like one of my favorite rides
at disney world yes
yeah yeah at uh hollywood studios for
malena's mgm my favorite
uh my favorite muppet is definitely
fozzie
bear because there's something about an
overweight hack
comedian that really resonates with me
i'm gonna put my number one
as dr teeth in the electric mayhem count
groups count if they're existing groups
you can't say like kermit plus ralph
plus miss piggy plus i can't be like
scooters
pepe the prawn i should have but i
didn't and if i had to choose one i
guess i would do
stalter and waldorf the old people at
the balcony stantler and waldorf yeah
they don't they are also a group so i
i'll say i'll say
i'll say the band i'll say the band i'll
say i am going to
give the point to uh jessica just for
having
in fact here i'm gonna give you two
points for having a document
but you can only get the second point if
you screen cap
some of that document and tweet it out
yes send me the document
jessica you're hardly on you're not on
twitter
i won't do it i will do it but i'm gonna
not i'm gonna delete the portion that
says why they are in there
okay that's fine you can you can't
redact part of it jessica said is to be
privately
send me your journal entries send me
your childhood diary
we just we learned something very
interesting about jessica she's got a
weird
muppet project yeah
i love pencil studios
oh i'm gonna cry you guys are making me
cry
well you shouldn't have told us it's
your fault uh
well uh that is it for this episode of
rogue theory congratulations to jessica
for winning this episode
um but thank you to all of our guests
jessica
and tommy bechtold and john xavier
miller be sure to follow all of them on
their social medias
and uh keep pressuring jessica to
release this weird muppet dog
we need to know the truth we're owed the
truth the truth is out there
and uh it's time to start the music it's
time to light the lights
it's time to make us happy with
jessica's weird doc
um so support our channel by checking
out one of our many great merch options
at new yorkstarsmerch.com they
these are still for sale and they are
awesome follow me at eavos follow new
york starts subscribe here on youtube be
sure to subscribe to the rogue theory
podcast feed wherever you get your
podcast leave us a nice writing review
and we'll see you next time bye
everybody goodbye
[Music]
you